I go
the time
the wall
hey wastelanders I'm Dave and welcome to
GameSpot's fallout mod of the week
this week we are taking a knee on the
grassy knoll to take a look at Hoth
troopers wastelands sniper mod Park
ghillie suit part settlers attire this
marksman's camouflage comes complete
with four versions or four the male or
female vault dweller whether you want to
stalk your way through the grey grassy
hills of the Commonwealth remain unseen
in the sands of the glowing sea hide in
the tallest trees or blend in with blood
and concrete in the cities of Boston
with an original desert forest and urban
version of this camouflage suit there's
really no reason for any Raider to set
eyes on you the inspiration for this mod
came from the creator usually defaulting
to the role of sniper during their first
playthrough the game although there was
really no suitable attire to match their
role there's plenty of detail in this
armor a ghillie suit style hood to keep
your face hidden and a chest webbing
containing cosmetic pouches filled with
bullets knives and really any other
supplies you may need for spending a
sustained amount of time lying in the
shrubs on your stomach this outfit has
firm roots in reality and it's perfectly
law friendly and even fits well in the
world of Fallout 4 I'd love to see the
mod expanded into the enemy characters
having one of the Gunners pin you down
and a sniper fire whilst you struggle to
see them under their ghillie suit cover
would make for some awesome emerging
gameplay and some really intense
situations the wasteland sniper outfit
can be made yourself at the chemistry
bench with all variations having their
own recipe as long as you have an armor
ranking of two or higher you can put all
your wasteland scrap to good use and
make yourself your own bush wookie suit
obviously I paired this suit with my
very own long-range munitions and with
Macready at my side we made for quite
the powerful sniper spotter team if you
want to adopt the life of the lone
hunter yourself then the link for the
mod page will be in the description if
you've used this mod yourself we would
love to hear what you think of it and if
you have any others you'd like to see on
the show make sure you tweet them at us
with the hashtag GS fallout I'll be back
next week with another episode and
another mod until then I've been Dave
and stay safe out there wasteland err
you